I know Tyson over says for many drivers
parking a vehicle with a horse trailer
attached to it is no laughing matter
heavens but he says VW's trailer assist
should help it's the system promoted in
this commercial with the Laughing horses
though when a VW tiguan with trailer
assist arrives the party's over
ABBA but does the system really help
while driving a vehicle with a trailer
attached let's see he says as a compact
SUV the Tiguan is well suited to this
task it boasts high ground clearance and
robust plastic cladding that offers good
underbody protection
and thanks to its all-wheel drive the
vehicle maintains a firm grip even on
slippery surfaces
horse lover Sophie health is going to
test what the Tiguan is like as a tow
vehicle she flips the switch in the
trunk to release the trailer hitch then
she uses the rear view camera to
maneuver the trailer precisely
does esteemeth Lionel says trailer
assist is easy to use and a big help
when reversing though he advises drivers
to practice a little in a parking lot
first still it's only a driver assist
and not a completely automated system he
feels a computer can never completely
replace a human's visual judgement it
takes just a few quick steps to connect
the electrical cable that delivers power
to the trailers taillights secure it and
turn the crank until the lock snaps into
place and Sophie's all ready to go for a
test drive our Tiguan is equipped with a
2 litre 110 kilowatt diesel engine
though it's the smallest diesel engine
available for this SUV it packs plenty
of pulling power its maximum 340 Newton
metres of torque at just 1750 rpm mean
it can pull away with ease even with a
trailer in tow
now comes the decisive part of the test
Sophie must back the trailer into a
designated parking spot
Jovie explains that she first put the
car into reverse like normal then she
presses the Park Assist button to
activate the trailer assist now she
steers the car using the mirror
adjustment joystick by pushing it to the
left or right depending on the direction
she wants to go no she wants to go left
so she presses left words
trailer assists relies on many
components that are already present Park
Assist power steering electric mirror
adjustment the rear-view camera and the
infotainment display all of these
components work together to prevent the
trailer from suddenly ending up in the
wrong place
Sophie says that at first it was a bit
strange to steer the car and the tree
there using just the little mirror
adjustment button but once you've done
it a few times it's relatively easy
especially because you can see the
direction you're going on this
infotainment display here Rhino says the
good news is trailer Assist works
straightaway the bad news is it costs
extra and you need to combine components
to make it work for instance the
rear-view camera and the trailer hitch
with the electrical installation kit the
system cost nine hundred thirty five
euros and the trailer hitch another
eight hundred eighty but trailer assist
does give drivers a sense of security so
they can relax when they're pulling a
big load even in tight spaces or
situations with poor visibility backing
up is no longer a problem